[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
everyone's having a great week
I'm Rachel I lead our Pro community at
posit and if this is your first time
joining us here
special welcome to you this is our open
space to chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to hear about what's going on in
the world of data across many different
Industries and so we're here every I say
every single Thursday there have been
some Thursdays where we haven't been
here for holidays or something but same
time same place so if you're watching
this on YouTube into the future
if you want to join us live you can use
the link in the details to add it to
your calendar and join the party with us
but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everyone and we love hearing from you
all no matter your level of experience
or area of work
so it's totally okay to just listen in
if you want but if you want to jump in
and ask questions or provide your own
perspective on certain topics there's a
few ways that you can do that so you can
raise your hand here on Zoom
um and if you're not sure how to do that
it's in the controls down below
but you can also put questions into the
zoom chat and feel free to put a little
star next to it if you wanted me to read
it out loud instead if you're in a
coffee shop or something
and then lastly we have a slider link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too and our team should share that in
the chat here in just a second
if not let me know and I can share it
but I'm so excited to have Catherine
joining me as our co-host today with
Catherine gertin is manager of data
analytics and Reporting at centene and
Catherine I'd love to kick things off
with having you introduce yourself and
share a little bit about your role and
also something you like to do outside of
work
yeah um hi I'm Catherine guertin I as
Rachel said in the manager of data
analytics and Reporting at centene
um in that role I actually support our
health insurance Affordable Care Act
Marketplace products
um supporting the risk adjustment
mandate that's part of part of that work
um I put it in my bio but when I am not
working I play volleyball and I do a lot
of sewing and so I've been working on
you know that's kind of what I got
better at during the pandemic was I
decided and I get actually good at
sewing more than a rectangle and I've
started making my own clothes so that is
what I do
I see we've got uh somebody else in the
chat who's also working in Risk
adjustment so that's nice
um I didn't want to get too into the
Weeds on what that actually is but I'm
more than happy to fill that in for
anyone who doesn't know
I also have to ask you what's one of
your favorite things that you've sewed
um I was really proud actually of a pair
of jeans that I made that I
embroidered with like outlines of
different fruit
so that's amazing
um they don't currently fit so they're
not getting a lot of use but they were
really great when I made them so we'll
see uh we'll see if they get a little
bit more aware here in the future
I would not know how to even start with
making jeans that's amazing
um well Catherine I know something that
you we had talked a little bit about and
it was shared in in advance of the
hangout was about the power of embedded
teams for kind of Bridging the Gap
between a lot of cool data science the
team's doing and then meaningful
business uh insights and I thought it
might be helpful to just understand a
little bit about the data analytics team
structure at suntean and what that looks
like yeah so we have it's kind of a
hybrid between you know your traditional
centralized team and your embedded teams
um within your your business areas so we
have a sunteen Technologies corporate
I.T
um kind of data data science data
analytics where they support a lot of
the tech stack
um but also facilitate conversations
with business teams that may not have
their own analysts they help gather
requirements build some of those models
and then we also have teams like the one
that I'm a part of within the Actuarial
department where we are a data science
team we are involved in gathering the
requirements building the tools
um to support that business process and
then interfacing with the centralized
teams that do control and maintain the
tech stack for us so that's
um really what we look like uh and I
would say like I'm super grateful to be
a part of that because not having to
know how computers work or how software
is built and installed and maintained
and all that is like great for me I am
I've tried to learn it it's not
something I really like
understand easily and it frees me up to
not have to really dig into that I can
spend my mental energy focusing on
okay these are the data science problems
also my cat is here
um these are the data science problems
that are facing my business unit and can
really dig into those problems
okay we're gonna have to introduce your
cat too okay that's Timber
um
we got her from the street
yes and my dog is around here somewhere
uh yeah he's over there snoozing you
might make an appearance too
awesome well I know you said you weren't
thinking about giving an overview about
risk adjustment risk adjustments but
while we're here and Libby asked it so
why don't we why don't we yeah so when
the Affordable Care Act
um was put into place in about 2015 one
of the things that was mandated there is
insurance companies can no longer deny
people coverage for pre-existing
conditions
um so it doesn't matter what conditions
you have you have to get insurance you
can't discriminate based on rates for
those conditions that someone has so one
of the things that is in place in order
to ensure that that happens is what's
called risk adjustment and so throughout
the year all health insurance companies
submit their claims data and their
diagnosis data for for their entire
populations to these government
maintained servers and then you get
credit for the risk so members have
certain conditions that counts them as
riskier or not risky there's a bunch of
interaction factors and a whole lot of
math involved in calculating how much
risk a member has
and so then at the end of the year is
when the risk adjustment takes place so
insurers who ensure a riskier population
actually get transfer dollars from the
insurers who insure a less risky
population so it's entirely budget
neutral there's no um
government money involved in changing
hands they facilitate that transfer
between those insurers but not
anything else so if one insurer insures
a bunch of like elderly people with
multiple comorbidities and one insurer
ensures a bunch of healthy college
students the one who ensures a bunch of
healthy college students is going to owe
money to that other insurer at the end
of the year
um just to say like we're covering more
risk than you are and then there's the
process so I have a sister team Who's
involved in the risk adjustment and I
I'm in charge of the audit of the risk
adjustment so once you've submitted all
of this data the government takes a
representative sample of your population
and comes back to you and say prove it
prove that these members have the
conditions that you say that they have
um so we have to go and collect medical
records talk to doctors code all of
those records and then recalculate the
risk and prove that the population
distribution is as risky as we said it
was throughout the year
interesting yes Libby said in the chat
that sounds like a huge data project
um what are are some of the like
projects that you work on in analytics
that come after that so there's a huge
part of this that's actually competitive
intelligence analytics where you know
because it is budget neutral and there's
transfers between different insurers you
know how risky your own population is
but you don't really know a lot about
the other insurers population so there's
a lot of data Gathering data aggregation
around
that relative risk analytics
um and then we also have
a bunch of analytics involved with
predicting which conditions are going to
be easy to validate which ones are going
to be more difficult what pieces of
information what might we need to gather
in the aspect of conducting this audit
in order to validate these conditions so
that's all the like post-hoc analytics
and then we also have a lot of
prospective analytics around identifying
members that we think may have
conditions that they haven't seen their
doctor for yet this year and closing
those care gaps um
and
this is reminding me of when uh Rebecca
Hadi uh joined us as well and her cat
was front and center for the hangout
yeah she of course as soon as I joined
the call decided that she needed
immediate attention
um that's how it goes
so that's that's like the overview of
risk adjustment
um and then some of the high level
work uh we're also involved since we are
embedded in the Actuarial Department
there's a lot of financial predictions
and analytics involved with forecasting
and reserving
um and all of that kind of stuff that
comes off of the data that you're
Gathering but then is involved with
licensed actuaries and that kind of um
business side of the work
thank you I see Libby you had a
follow-up question on the the audits you
want to jump in yeah I was just
wondering if there's a really busy time
of year for you like I know I've done
Audits and I have worked with audit
teams in different areas and there's
always like this really busy month or
week out of the quarter yeah so we
kicked off the audit last week that was
incredibly busy uh there's a lot of
vendor data handoffs where we have to
gather gather that information pass it
to back to the government back to other
vendors who help us with certain aspects
of the audit and then there's usually a
pretty busy season about two months
before the audit closes when you're
trying to aggregate all of the
information that you've gathered so that
you can submit it and then also do some
of those financial forecasts
nice so do you have oh sorry I have
follow-up do you have like this this
period where there is a little bit less
stuff to do and you're able to start to
like work on problems that would make it
easier for for their audits yeah so we
have um my team's been building a lot of
shiny apps and a lot of dashboards that
we've been deploying onto our posit
connect Suite um that track kind of like
how the audit is going where there might
be points of intervention if there's
something that's like Hey we're not
doing it as well as this as we were last
year flagging that sending emails
um
a lot of that we've also uh made some
data portals where some of our internal
Partners where they might need something
in a specific format like an Excel file
or a CSV so they can do some additional
work with it where they can like upload
data or download our results in a way
that makes it really accessible for them
to continue doing their work but in more
of a self-service way so it's not like
an email to us and then we have to like
manually create some sort of or even
just manually run in our script it's
like part of that dashboarding so we're
actually
um kind of shifting into that for this
audit now of like maintaining what we've
done in the past updating it with some
with some new tools with some new
new shiny development as well as just
there's always Lessons Learned From from
last year's like oh we weren't tracking
that but we really should have been
um and so we're tracking it this year
I love to learn more about that shiny
app too so can you mentioned people can
download the data
as well is that people who typically
would want to be working with like Excel
data or what are they yeah so that's
people who would want to be working with
Excel data or
we have um so I sit at centene corporate
but we also have subsidiary health plans
and so certain I have access to all of
our health plan data but not everyone
who supports the audit execution at the
lower levels does so when they go in
they can just see like the California
data or just the
um certain like pre-filtered sets of it
that's really kind of tied to their
their login credentials all that kind of
stuff
um
so that again yeah I don't have to be
like okay who's asking for this what
health plan do they support filtering it
on my end we were able to build those
those things tied to their internal
login credentials and then they can just
do it
that's great
so a question we used to ask in the
beginning of the Hangouts and I don't
know what happened where we stopped
asking this but I'm curious like what's
something if you look to the year ahead
what's something that you're really
excited about for your team
we have been working really hard on
turning some
okay statistical models
um into some machine learning models
where we can bring in some different
data types and get a little bit more
insight out of that so we have a couple
different models that are in the works
around
estimating our final validation rates
for for these audits or
um estimating some of those like
Statewide competitive intelligence
variables
and where it's something that we've done
in the past on like an ad hoc basis with
different you know hand grabbing
different Excel files and things like
that so we've been working really hard
to kind of bake that into our data
science ecosystem where it runs on our
database queries and it gathers things
like that and we're currently in the
stage of like figuring out how to deploy
those so that people can access the
results again
the theme the theme of a lot of the work
that we're doing is
not like purely self-service but like
mostly self-service where somebody who
wants this can can get it and knows how
to get it
how do you like Market those
applications out across the organization
so we have
um
for those applications we're not really
targeting whole organization reach we
have a couple specific
um Partners during audit execution that
we really Target with those where
they've
you know they'll ask us for an ad hoc
thing and that's fine but if we you know
get those same requests more than twice
really it's okay let's put it together
here it's going to run every week it's
going to come straight to your inbox
um and everyone's like oh this is great
um we haven't really had a lot of
pushback with those internal teams on
like well no I really need you to walk
me through this Excel file or things
like that where
and that's definitely something I'm
grateful for because it's not something
that happens everywhere where the
partners that I work with are
fully on board to receive automatic like
HTML markdowns in their inbox
I see there is some conversation in the
chat going on about like shiny
Frameworks and I think Bill you maybe
had the initial question here I don't
know if you're able to unmute bill
but Bill asked are you using any
specific shiny frame Frameworks like
Gollum
no we've actually had a lot of success
with like
bs4 Dash
um kind of those interactive like
tabular kind of things
um so no really in-depth shiny
Frameworks a lot of interactivity and a
lot of a lot of tabs and click through
um
but yeah nothing nothing super high
level shiny more of just that
facilitating that interaction
yeah and I see people are talking about
both like Rhino and Gollum as well
Alexis I wasn't sure if you wanted to
share any thoughts on this too I see
commenting in the chat
yeah um actually uh I've been trying
Rhino has been a little bit
um more oriented towards um software
development and uh
I think a balance a balance between
Golem and for people that are just
starting and if you want to go more in
depth I think we'll go with Rhino
however I think volume has been pretty
good uh as a starting point for uh for
shiny models
yeah I mean I'll that I haven't because
the the dashboards that I'm building are
really used by like a limited set of
internal Partners I haven't really had
to worry about things like shiny load
testing or all of those kinds of like
broader things that you worry about when
you build an app that hundreds if not
your whole company of people is going to
use
if I have three people in my app at the
same time like that's heavy use on the
app on that day
um just because
like there's not a lot of need for it so
the most like complicated and business
important app that I've built is really
it was a way for me to have to not
email for people get four different
versions of an Excel sheet back and
collapse it and then do analytics on it
I you know made a portal where they can
go in everyone with their login
credentials edit basically the Excel
file but in the shiny app through like
an R Hands-On table format and save it
in exactly the format that I wanted and
nobody can move anything and nobody can
change data types and it's great and but
it's really specifically to people who
have those senior coding level
credentials and there's like four of
them that support this audit so I think
for my team business value is not
measured in number of users or reach of
that app it's really the fact that this
saved us
so much time and so much money to do it
in this way that like
that's the value of this app for my team
okay a lot of love for our Hands-On
table or yeah I was trying to find just
like the quick link to it I'm not sure
if that was the right one but what is
that actually do that package so it lets
you click into a data frame
and make edits and save those edits back
out so those edits can then be re
redisplayed to the user
um it's delightful it's a little bit
hard to learn if you're used to maybe
like a GT or a GT data table
but it's basically magical you can put
this table in your shiny app and people
can feel if you wanted to you can even
make it green if you want people to
really feel like it's Excel you can
um but you're basically putting this in
in your shiny app and people are editing
it but you can sit you can say this is a
date data type this is exactly the date
format that it's coming in this is going
to be a number it's going to have three
decimal places and when they hit save
that's exactly what you get back
um and I have that linked to our S3
storage solution so every time somebody
hit save it's a separate record like we
can go back we can access historical
records
it's made my life so much better and I
think you know
building tools that make your own life
better and then like spreading them to
other people is still a really valuable
way to do work
I was just writing that down to save
that quote there
um I can feel the excitement in the chat
right now about people like just
discovering this package as well and I
I need to look into it too but it sounds
like it would be really helpful for the
people who have this use case of
um they're working with business users
who still really want to use Excel and
don't want to be interacting with a
shiny application but maybe need to like
download their own Excel data as well
okay cool yeah it's great um and then
I'm not as comfortable with I think it's
tidy XL but that's one of the ones that
enables you to like when you write your
format back out to in Excel you can bake
in formulas like if somebody said like
hey I really need like this formula to
come out of it for some reason not
static data like let's make it somehow
dynamic in the Excel file that you're
writing like all those things still work
together even through that shiny backend
awesome thank you uh Regis I saw you had
a question in the chat I missed it with
all the the comments here but if you
want to jump in
yeah
um let me turn my camera really quick so
I was just wondering Libby was saying
yes so hopefully that's the case
um so I've been I've made a couple shiny
apps that require tables that have
editing and the out of the box tables
that you make and maybe Joe Chang is
going to change Just for future
iterations of shining
um but if you're on page 10 of a table
that has a thousand rows and then you
need to change what's in the table by
default shiny will reset that table back
to the first page of the table but
has some extensions for the DT package
where
um if you need to change something in
page 10 you can I think there's a
replace data function in the DT package
and I'm just worried if our Hands-On
data has something like that so that if
you're on page 10
um and you're doing something super
fancy in our Hands-On table that it
won't send you back to page one which
will drive everyone using it crazy yeah
so there's um
offering but when you click into a cell
you can store that row and sell value
um so that's one of the things that I do
with like the reactives and the
callbacks is I store this and then you
can index anything that you're doing
based on that or like send it back to
pull up this page pull up this row or
any changes that you're making can be
tagged with that cell that you've
clicked in
but I mean when you when you change it
on the back end the the shiny side the r
side and then you push it back to the
interface
is there does it make sure that it
doesn't set the table that it's
displaying back to the first page if you
edit something on the 10th page
first event reactives
um because observers I think execute all
the time
um so if you put your table render in an
observe it's going to automatically go
but if you wait you can save it and have
it wait to re-render until after you
click some other button so you can store
all of that data and then not render
your table until you're ready and I
think you can also set it to render if
you save that page you can have it
re-render on page 10.
um oh okay so you can say this is the
page to stay at yeah not something that
I've built directly but I've seen some
like pieces around doing something like
that
yeah and I think Jeff is saying use
input DT row last clicked and Rose
selected but that's for the D I mean
does DT in our hands our table work
together do they work together and is
that how
because those are DT anyway maybe we're
getting into I don't know this is It's a
hangout I don't I don't know where the
line is so I'm seeing
um in the comments somebody had
recommended doing like a a deep dive on
this topic and I will definitely take
that on as an action item and ask who
from our team it might be interesting
something that so many people on data
teams have to deal with is like it
doesn't matter how
powerful your back end is if ultimately
like the business user who maybe has an
analyst on their team who's maybe
comfortable in Excel and can write some
SQL like it doesn't it doesn't matter if
they can't interact with it as your
deliverable and not everything that you
deliver is suitable for an HTML markdown
like sometimes clickable graphs are what
you need but sometimes like people
really like tables and people really
need tables and so there there are
certain things there where you have to
like
meet people where they are on data
science it doesn't do you any good to be
like well have you tried doing it in R
if the person doesn't like even know
what that is
so yeah I think that's really really
where I'm at on on some of these things
where I'm like I have no hate for excel
don't love it but I have no hate for it
absolutely thank you
um I Know Travis you had a question I
think was maybe touched upon but I want
to make sure we answer it
fully if you want to jump in here
sure I know um persistent data storage
particular writing to data stores is not
always easy and shiny
um sounds like you're using S3
good experience I suppose
um like I'm curious if you're using our
hands on table I'm actually really
curious about the way that someone would
enter data into it and um and then send
it to the
to the database I suppose all right
because it's generally easy to like
report out from it and pull things in
and summarize them but like sending
stuff is harder at least to me um maybe
you've solved it so we've solved it in
kind of like two ways that we then work
together
um my team built a package that helps us
like handle our internal S3 credentials
um so that the app has the serviced
account credentials the app has access
to S3 as part of like setting up our
environment variables so that was the
first thing that we did
um that didn't make it so that the
individual user needed to have the right
S3 access to the bucket
um and then I also I'll say invented
nobody invented this but invented it for
this app
we've got the submit button and we also
have a save for later button where
in terms of just like naming these files
it's like okay is this done save it for
later every time you want to save
something you can you can send it to S3
and it saves that portion of data that I
would expect regardless of what's in it
and it's tagged with that like
intermediate tag and then when they hit
submit
then it's tagged with that done and what
I actually have as part of that
interaction is in that display when
you're going to say okay what rows do I
need to edit it brings that tag back in
so the user knows what's already been
changed what are they like maybe still
working on versus what are they
comfortable with that done but really
just like a we've got it as a save RDS
really from that S3 call just save the
RDS because I'm the only one and my team
who's going to have access to like oh
hey I need to know what I did last month
I can go back and I can read RDS and
write it to that to that file for that
person
that's super cool it's for the S3 needs
um is that just on your shiny team
people that are maintaining that
back-end infrastructure do you have
Cloud support as well like so we have um
that's part of that corporate I.T kind
of centralized they maintain our S3
storage so Actuarial has our own storage
we also have like a broader sentine
storage
um and things like that and the IT team
is in charge of maintaining that and as
I said at the beginning that's one of
the things that I'm grateful that I
don't have to know how how to do it um
but I'm also very grateful that the
technology solution exists and that I
have access to it
loving all of this table discussion here
too
um I did just want to share in the chat
I just learned that rich who maintains
the GT package started a GT Discord
server
um which has been really helpful for
people to ask questions there too
um Alan I see you had asked a question
in the chat do you want to jump in here
next
yeah
hi um this is super fun uh I'd love when
the chat is just like excited and
everybody is is like enthusiastic and
learning stuff it's really really fun
um at the risk of like
pivoting away from that Catherine I'm
super curious what your kind of
day-to-day is like we're super we're
obviously like in the technical leads
here and it's really great what's the
balance of that for you with leading or
managing or doing strategic stuff you
know that kind of thing like what's the
um how much of that do you do and what's
your what's your experience doing that
as a leader of the
um you know working with the team that
you're working with
yeah um
so I would say
I'm pretty maybe like
60 40 leadership to in in the data
um and I think a lot of that comes from
the fact that I have been at centene I
started there as like a data scientist
one
um and I'm now a manager of a data
analytics team so a lot of the things
that I learned as a data science
databases that I as a data scientist
databases that I got access to things
like that where I'm like really
comfortable with certain pieces of the
job
is still really helpful for me to be
doing because I can still do it
reasonably quickly
um and all of that and my team is also
pretty small I have two direct reports
and my sister team has three and so
together we're like a data science org
of about eight
and so we're a pretty small team and so
there's still a lot of Need for like hey
can you do this for me really quick
um but in terms of like strategic
leadership
um and direct management of my team
there's a lot involved in in terms of
making sure that us as an embedded team
stay up to date on what the tech stack
development looks like and where those
tools are going to live and how can we
make sure that we maintain access to the
new tools and potentially transition
processes but also keep support for
these processes that aren't ready to be
transitioned yet so there is a lot of
that strategic leadership in terms of
project maintenance because
when you're the Actuarial Department of
an insurance company you can't just like
not file a rate or not turn something in
into the government all of this work
still needs to go on while you're doing
all of the like forward initiatives with
your with your data science so
there's a lot of that and then I've
personally been a lot more involved I'm
on the Leadership Council for our women
in stem initiatives so there's a lot of
that sort of
and enter our user group but I kind of
that's a given here on the r on the r
hangout but
there's a lot of that community building
and reaching out to people that I've
kind of incorporated into some of my
leadership work of
a lot of things is like making sure you
know that other teams exist
um which in an organization at the size
of centene can be really difficult just
like
oh I didn't know that this team was
doing this kind of thing with membership
I have a need to do something with
membership let me make sure that I know
who to reach out to
um and that's something that we've been
really working hard on in our next
internal our user group meeting and
we're trying to do it a little bit in
everyone moving forward is
someone just highlighting their team and
this is what we're doing this is how
we're using the centene tools maybe it's
not always our but it's just this is how
we're using our data this is the data
science that we're kind of doing
um to keep those relationships built
again I think going back to something I
said earlier like I did it for me and
then I'm more than happy that it's
helping helping other people
also um incenting
it's great thank you I really appreciate
hearing that I also
um uh
I was curious also about your sort of
Journey to the role that you're in so
knowing that you started as data
scientists have moved into and through
the organization is also uh it's also
really interesting to know thank you
appreciate it yeah you're welcome
um I don't think my journey into data
science is particularly different from
anyone else's on this call
um I have an applied science background
I have biomedical engineering and
applied math and I didn't want a PhD so
I got a data science job and I think
that's a story that will resonate with
many people on this call
I want to make sure I get to some of the
anonymous questions too I see somebody
had asked
um on slido
and I think it was when you were
describing the shiny app you created
perhaps but it was is this aggregated
information across all suppliers
provided on some de-identified way
through the public or all the suppliers
it is not provided to the public it is
anonymized but it is not de-identified
to the point of meeting
um like HIPAA compliance so this is
individual data that we that we get back
um
summary results by state and potentially
by Health Plan are available
at the end of the audit
um on the government HHS websites but
you would not have access to this member
level ACA Marketplace information
anywhere
okay thank you
Lisa IC had just asked the question here
in the zoom chat you want to jump in
sure I had to move down to my first
floor because our second floor is like a
sauna here and you know I'm in Minnesota
we've gone from winter to summer very
quickly
um
yeah I was just sort of curious
um how your teams work
uh divides up maybe between like machine
learning type tasks and then other
you know reporting summarizing
presenting
essentially every other kind of data
science work and then like if that
you know do you feel like uh the
organization or business sort of
appreciates both pieces of that work and
does
um sort of like how much it's getting
noticed and used kind of match with how
much time you're spending in each of
those
um I would definitely say yes to the
second part of that
um my organization and my reporting
pipeline
very interested in those kinds of like
machine learning improvements not just
for the sake of saying that we're doing
machine learning but for the sake of
this is improving this forecast that we
have or this thing like that we're
thrilled that there are tools available
to help us improve that so that's great
and then in terms of balancing the work
um because we do have busy Seasons with
audit conduction and then
a little bit of downtime before we're
back up on audit we tend to do a lot of
the data science work during our
downtime of audit because those are the
things that make when we do kick off the
audit easier but also during that time
we have a lot more less technical
business partners who need
summarizations of of that data they need
weekly reporting in a downloadable
format or a graph or things like that so
for us we're lucky that a lot of those
things have been able to be automated
based on the way that we're storing and
accessing
um and running these reports but there's
still plenty of Need for like I think
like I said like oh we weren't tracking
that last year now we have nothing in
place to track that because it's a
problem and doing some of that that
scramble there's always some of that
data wrangling data display scramble
when you run into a new issue and then
during our downtime we bake that in to
models to reporting
um things like that so that we don't run
into it next year
thanks
thank you
um for for a reason I see you had asked
a question in the chat do you want to
jump in here next
uh sure
um I was just asking actually kind of
what your Tech stack is so is are you
running pause it sort of in the cloud
are you running it locally
um the reason I'm asking the question is
I'm from Canada also in insurance but we
have very strict rules around our data
so we've only been able to stay locally
for right now so I'm just kind of
curious how you ended up building out
that stack but
yeah so we have
um
some of the posit professional tools we
have the package manager and rs connect
I think we're currently running R in
Jupiter Hub
um through that but all of our data is
on-prem right now
um and so our corporate centralized I.T
has built a lot of product protections
around different environments where you
can publish things and it needs to be
approved through the certain pipeline
for Phi and and all of that kind of
stuff so there are some there's some
heavy considerations with publishing any
information
um even internally for internal use
um going back to like not everyone has
access to the same level of Phi within
this organization so being really
careful about where that's displayed
um all like I said all of our databases
are on-prem and then those different
environments that they've set up um have
access to different levels of that
information
thank you
and maybe if there is anybody else who's
based in Canada and wants to comment in
the chat to
help Theresa as well
feel free
um another anonymous question was how
has the push for value-based care
impacted how your risk adjustment is
done
so value-based care
um
for those who are not aware is a method
of paying providers based on
like some Metric of care value that
they're providing whether it is risk
adjustment capture whether it is
medication management or whatever it's
usually a contractual arrangement with
your provider so it's something not all
providers are in value-based care
arrangements and that's not actually
from you know the grand scheme of
government mandated risk adjustment they
don't care what what your provider
Arrangement looks like
um so for us on the back end that's part
of that's part of plan design so if
we're going to say like these members
can sign up for this kind of network
within this value-based care arrangement
we still there might be different
premiums associated with that different
aspects of the plan design that feed the
risk adjustment transfers
um
so what that comes down to in terms of
risk adjustment is understanding the
population that is participating in that
plan
um so different people may choose to
select different plans based on their
own personal needs on on the marketplace
and so understanding what is driving
whatever subset of members to enroll in
these plans is really where some of the
analytics that our risk adjustment
Actuarial team is doing because of how
you price it how you design that then
you come back and say okay well what is
the risk of these members
thank you I think that we are not doing
the best job of tracking with some of
the questions in between some of this
well I see there's a lot of that around
Zelda and how hot it is currently Libby
and I are both in San Antonio and it is
hot it's we're reaching like don't go
outside Susan so
well I know there are a lot of of great
questions in there too so feel free to
just raise your hand here on Zoom if
there was something you had that that we
missed
um but I see Libby you had a question
about
uh moving from Individual contributor
role do you want to jump in there yeah
this is always like my most this is the
thing I'm most interested in always it's
like you have moved from an individual
contributor role to something that at
least involves people management project
management like bigger stuff that might
pull you away from boots on the
groundwork how do you feel about that
how did you feel about making that
transition
um and how has that been how did that
come to be
um
I feel great about it I
it was
um I think it's something that fits
within like
my personal evaluation of my own skill
set so like I was ready
um
for that transition but I think one of
the things that really helped me with
that is like in my individual
contributor role there were certain
projects that I was wholly responsible
for already
um and so I knew a little bit about
managing that project what was involved
in terms of talking to the people so I
was already doing that for myself
and then as I got promoted in my
pipeline I actually had a really great
leadership Mentor
um talking me through how he was
managing his team
um setting setting me up with like okay
now that you're taking over this
responsibility these are my primary
contacts so somebody really
set me up for success in that transition
into
um the people leadership something that
I've had to balance with myself is
part of that of like there are certain
things that I am very good at um and I
have a lot of experience with within
within 17 but now if I choose to spend
my time doing that that's time that I'm
taking away from something else so
balancing that like I do need to train
people to do this task because that's no
longer my primary responsibility is
something that I've been navigating and
trying to get better at especially
during times when it's not like hey we
need to turn this around in three hours
because like if that's the deadline I'm
gonna do it but if we have 24 hours or
even three weeks like that's something
that I can
spend the time teaching someone how to
do it right once and then facilitating
that in the future
that's really helpful thank you yeah
was there a specific point where you
thought okay I'm ready to move from this
individual contributor role
um
I don't think so
um I think it was just something that
like
my my recording chain was generally very
supportive of moving any people through
the career direction that they want to
go and so as I went from data scientist
one to data scientists 2 and my
responsibilities grew and I was feeling
comfortable it was a like hey do you
think you're ready for this and I said
sure and then once you stay sure that
you're ready for it you then have to be
because now you're doing it
um and there's no room to be like oh
just kidding let me um you know please
unpromote me so it's uh yeah yeah you I
felt like I was ready and then as I made
that transition like my reporting chain
was still intact and so I still had that
support from the top down to help me as
I learned how to support the people that
now report to me
something that's been hard for me is
like when that
um career track doesn't already exist or
your role like figuring out how to
then go from Individual contributor to a
manager and if it's like creating your
own role or finding a different part
within the organization where that would
fit in as well
yeah so I think that's something
um we've kind of worked with our HR
Partners
um being embedded in the Actuarial
Department
I think before I was hired in as a data
scientist everyone in that work had to
have Actuarial titles even though these
were people not pursuing Actuarial
credentials or or anything like that so
there was a big push to say like okay
we're actually allowed to hire people
with data titles
into this role
um so there's it can feel like there's a
lot of like swimming Upstream there
because there there is Corporate inertia
for there's a reason that these orgs
were built this way when it started but
having having someone who understands
that like the corporate needs are
changing and there's a need to hire
people with these different skills can
be really valuable in in designing that
and then
like if you're moving into a management
position but there hasn't historically
been one it's working with them to say
okay well what do these job posts look
like in other orbs going through the
whole process of okay let's just copy
and paste that but put it in this order
or maybe we need to change what tools
does this person have to know but that's
part of that that conversation
thank you
um Zachary I see you had asked the
question in the chat there's Stars next
to it so I'll read it but it was how do
you and your team generally keep track
of all the r packages uh for example we
discussed so many even in this hangout
and also new packages that come out
there's just so much
so we have um in our bi-weekly team
meeting after we go around and we say
what everyone's been working on what do
they need any help with we actually have
a little slide that's called our
Spotlight and there's a web scraper that
just runs and it lists all like oh
here's you know what's from the new in
this packages from the um
blanking on the name of that like our
weekly I think it might be our weekly
um update it kind of like scrapes that
and just plops it into our team slides
for us and so
um when me or the other manager have a
little time before the meeting we'll go
through that and kind of pick out the
ones that we think we should
individually highlight
um
but even that we've got some like
keyword searches
um
but it brings it in so it always stays
on our radar even if you're not paying
super close attention
um and then we also have within our data
science Community a couple
um our devoted channels so if somebody's
asking a question about a package or
about something that they heard we can
keep an eye on that and be like oh okay
yeah there's now been four questions
about this package let's learn a little
bit more about it so
all about to say I think I kind of
outsourced uh knowing everything that's
going on in R
um to the point that where it does
filter to the top of my Consciousness
that's something that I actually you
know should learn about
that's great thank you I was just
copying over the chat or into the chat
our weekly as well for people to check
out
um Greg I see you have a question in the
chat here too do you want to jump in
yes are you hear me yeah take me a
minute to get off mute no worries uh
yeah so I I heard at the beginning you
mentioned that uh if you get multiple
requests for the same thing that you'll
then you know talk about building
something that's self-service or an app
or whatever it might be
um to keep track of all those you you
maintain any kind of like data analytics
uh roadmap or do you do anything to like
assess the value of multiple requests
yeah so our primary method for for
tracking that is actually we use git lab
and we have issues and epics and
Milestones
um related to a lot of that and then can
use the comments of like God asked for
this again
um something like that to to prioritize
we have been
um we have been having to do a lot more
with
value analytics
um in terms of saying like to prioritize
our work because we've started getting
more and more as we've integrated with
more teams taking on more
responsibilities to say like okay well
what's the priority for us and what's
divorcing the
this is valuable to me and my team and
would save us time versus
this is what's valuable to the
organization and this is the amount of
money that we will save or not spend or
whatever if we implement this
um
is something that does require a little
bit of tracking and a little bit of
we have we work with our corporate I.T
Partners to say like okay if we put this
much data on this storage solution how
much is that going to cost to maintain
it in this way
um and all of those kinds of discussions
that goes back to what are my
responsibilities now as a manager versus
an individual contributor is having
having to think about stuff like that
um but a lot of it is
in terms of like the multiple requests
it would be like we ran a report once
and it was ad hoc and now we've gotten
asked for it a couple times so the code
still exists and it's not a lot of
ground up development it's just a matter
of like
putting it in the right spot so like on
RS connect and just scheduling it or
something like that where it's not a
huge lift there but it is then gets us
more cred as like we've got another
thing published and then you have some
of those other considerations about like
login and Phi and stuff like that once
you get it get it to that point so it's
not no development
but it's not ground up the ground up
work takes a lot more
um value prioritization
sure cool I appreciate that
so is that a budget that you have to
control like the spend
the storage spend for example
I am not in charge of it but I need to
be aware of it the person in charge of
the budget ultimately decides whether or
not they're willing to spend the budget
on the value that you've built around
your project
um so making not only Gathering the
value and determining it but then
saying hey I need you to spend your
money on this project
um some of it is our money that we that
we control but some of it is
um corporate spend dollars for different
aspects of I.T development uh technology
spend things like that so you have to
come in and then they have their own
prioritization for projects and
different other teams who have data
science needs and Technology needs maybe
they need it today and I don't need it
for two months and so that kind of
prioritization then you're like oh great
I'm done with this and then you have to
like keep it on your back burner for two
months and not lose sight of it as it
goes through that whole process
thank you I I see Bill had asked a
question a bit earlier that was do you
have a corporate structure with a
distinctive function which assures
compliance with government regulations
if so does your team
sorry it's a little longer question if
so does your team I.T and compliance
which could maybe be called QA and
Pharma work together on your
applications
yeah so we do have
um we have a compliance team we have so
we have like government compliance teams
and then we also have like I.T socks
compliant teams
um and do both of those things do need
to come together there's code review
there's
um
distinction of data access reviews as
you go through
um publishing these apps so those
those teams are not married government
compliance and I.T compliance like
officially but both of those pieces have
to come together in order to get
something in the works
I love what you said about making sure
that you know other teams exist across
the organization and like figuring out
what everybody else is working on and I
was wondering like aside from
the community event how do you start to
build those relationships or figure out
like in such a large organization
who you should talk to
I think it it starts small
um like when you're when you're really
close to a data project and you there's
one piece that you don't know
um it's like shooting the email to the
person that you saw last accessed that
that database because you can check
those things you can say like hey I saw
you were using this data like
what's going on with it
um and so those kinds of small emails
and it's also getting over that hump of
like
self-doubt of like oh am I emailing the
right person are they going to you know
hate me for derailing their day for
emailing the wrong person and just like
send email because the worst thing that
happens is that they don't respond to
you and then you send an email to to
another person
um and building that out and then as
I've moved through into a leadership
role it's getting plugged in with other
team leaders where they okay like now I
know the name of your team but do you
have somebody on your team who knows
about this or who can help with this um
and that's also something that like the
women in stem group has helped with
because we have women in stem across the
entire organization they are not just in
corporate I.T as your Cloud Engineers
like
almost anyone with a data analyst title
or anything like that could could count
and a lot of people in health insurance
have those math backgrounds that like
I've been exposed to so many more people
and so many more incredible women at
centene
through through that other organization
that now I know there's there's a new
team Our member insights team
um
brand new team but I'm like their their
manager immediately got plugged in with
women and some and so now I'm connected
to her on like both pieces so it's
really great
to be able to have that
yeah I I love that
um it's a great great Community anecdote
there like it doesn't just have to be
the data science Community where you are
meeting all these other people across
different parts of the organization
um just want to double check with
everybody here in the chat I think there
are a lot of people who I think need to
play some sort of game together because
there's a lot of talk about a certain
game
um but just want to make sure there were
no other questions that I might have
missed
okay one question I love to ask for my
own knowledge here is if you think
um back to your your career and as
you're getting to got into your role now
is there
a piece of advice that kind of comes to
mind that you received along the way or
a favorite piece of it career advice
that you've ever given
I think
um
it's something that even coming into
this meeting where I'm like
I'm great and then I'm also like oh my
goodness what if people find out I'm not
great
um who are like
that that sort of
um that sort of imposter syndrome of
just like
let people believe in you until you can
believe in yourself where it's like no
one's giving you opportunities that they
don't think that you can do
um because everybody's looking out for
themselves so even like
I've given that advice I give myself
that advice because it is like
let other people
um believe in you and I think that
that's
that's something that makes the most
difference and it it comes even back
around to like
if you think you're you're doing okay
like send that email to the stranger and
hope that they can help you with um
like with your data
so it's just like yeah
you probably have the opportunities that
you have because you earned them
I absolutely love that thank you so much
Catherine
um is if people want to get in touch
with you is the best way LinkedIn
um it is I am not generally Super Active
on posting okay on social media but I am
a scroller so if you reach out to me on
LinkedIn I will get it
awesome I just put it in your LinkedIn
there in the chat as well and it'll be
up with the recording on the the data
science hangout site but thank you so
much Catherine this has been a great
conversation and thank you for sharing
your experience with us all yeah thank
you for having me